in the last video we started to explore
the payments that could flow into a
country or out of a country and now i
want to continue it more in particular
we focused on the current account last
time and that focused on things like
trade exports and imports income earned
from assets in another country or income
that someone from outside of the country
earns from assets in the country that
we're studying or just transfers that
are happening now when we look at the
capital count in this video right over
here and i wrote capital accounts there
shouldn't be an s right there when we
look at the capital account we'll look
at other ways of act or other reasons
why we might have inflows or outflows of
payments and in particular the capital
account is focused on is focused on the
change in
the change in assets that either
foreigners own of in this case the us or
that u.s nationals own
of assets that are someplace else and
this little triangle right over here
that is the greek letter delta just
shorthand for change in so once again
let's focus focus focus flow
let's focus first on the inflows and
when you're talking about change in
assets these would essentially be
someone outside the us
buying assets inside the u.s from some
from someone that was not foreign so for
example if i am a home builder i'm an
american citizen i'm a home builder i
build a home in the u.s
and then i sell it and it's four million
dollars to a mexican national maybe for
their vacation home that means that on
for just that transaction you there's
been an increase in foreign ownership of
u.s assets that million dollar home and
so this number this number would be
increased would be increased by a
million dollars and so that's why it's
an inflow because when they bought that
house they would have had to make a
payment to me and this right over here
you have a bunch of stuff written over
here change in foreign owned assets in
u.s and it also includes financial
derivatives here you don't have to worry
too much about that it also has change
in for foreign and foreign reserves the
one way to think about the difference
between that and that right over there
this is you could view this as privately
owned changes in ownership and this is
by
essentially official changes in
ownership by either the government or
the federal res or the central banks of
foreign countries and for a lot of
countries they're essentially one in the
same thing in the u.s they kind of
maintain this pseudo independence but
this is this is official you could kind
of view this as official government
ownership and this right over here is
for the most part private ownership so
once again if someone in england were to
come into the us and buy let's say buy a
a share of ibm from an american then
that would increase this number right
over here but if the
central bank of china decided to buy a
u.s government bond from from some from
an american then this right over here
then this right over here would increase
but they're both the general idea
someone buys an asset not we're not
talking about the income on the asset
we're talking about the asset itself
someone buys an asset from or changes
hands from a a an american national to a
foreign national then these numbers
would increase and those foreign
nationals would have to make a payment
into the u.s so once again these are
inflows right over here now we take the
other side of that coin
if i were to go out and buy a vacation
home in italy and let's say i buy it
from an italian then i would have to
make a payment to them so that would be
an outflow from the u.s and it would be
and i would get an asset in italy in
exchange for it my vacation home and so
that this number this number right over
here would increase but once again i
wrote it over here in orange because it
is an outflow i'm making a payment to a
foreign national and this once again
this is a breakdown between this is
really the private sector for the most
part and this over here is the u.s
u.s federal
federal reserve so if the u.s federal
reserve were to go and buy an asset from
a foreign government bank or individual
let's say a foreign bond then this
number then this number right over here
would increase and actually the way i've
classified it right over here government
purchases not the us federal reserve but
the us government actually still falls
into this category just the way i've set
up the numbers this right over here is
the federal reserve alone now with that
out of the way let's actually figure out
whether we're running a capital account
deficit or a surplus so let's get our
calculator back
let me again i'll put it right over here
so we can see our numbers and so let's
think about the inflows so this is how
much more foreigners are buying of u.s
stuff so they're buying 625 and when i
say stuff i'm talking about assets i'm
not talking about goods and services i'm
talking about stocks and bonds and real
estate so
billion and then plus another 165
billion if we talk about the official
purchases of governments and central
banks so this is how much increased
asset this is the change in assets
purchased from foreigners in the u.s so
they had to put in 790 billion dollars
in 2011 to make those purchases well on
the other side of that
americans went out and bought 380
billion and when i write that's answer
that's just the previous answer so we
have 790 billion which is what's
inflowing and now this is what's
outflowing 380 billion to buy assets in
other countries that that the
non-federal reserve actors do and then
let's these are the assets that the
federal reserve also buys but those are
also outflows of payments
and we are left with
394 billion a positive 394 billion this
is 394 billion larger than this right
over here so we're running a capital
account surplus
let me write that so this is so we end
up with
we end up with a capital capital
capital account
capital account surplus
surplus and he shows you how good moves
at 300 and
394 billion 395
billion and so you see that these
numbers are pretty close and now i'm
going to tell you something and you'll
and hopefully in future videos we'll
understand why this is happening in a
little bit more depth but these numbers
actually should have been the exact same
thing these numbers should have actually
been the exact same thing but we see
that they're off by about what is
they're off by about 80 billion so let
me write this down we have an 80 billion
dollar discrepancy and then for most
people that's a fairly large discrepancy
but if we're talking about an economy
the size of the united states that's on
the order of 15 trillion it's not that
huge of a discrepancy
discrepancy and you have to think about
how all of this stuff is measured they
have to do surveys they sample things
you know they're getting all these
numbers from all different sources and
so it's actually reasonable that you
would have some form of statistical
discrepancy and that's actually what
this is right over here this is a
statistical
statistical discrepancy in theory these
numbers should be the exact amount the
amount if you're running a current
account deficit then you should have
that exact same amount in the capital
account surplus and vice versa if you
have a capital account deficit then you
would have to be running a current
account surplus we'll talk more about
why that makes sense all i encourage you
to think about it think about it right
now why that makes sense and the
difference between these numbers this is
just a statistical discrepancy by the
bureau of economic analysis